path of exile's newly announced update
brings new items and end game challenges
for long time players here's the four
biggest changes you need to know about
the biggest addition is the prophecy
challenge league you'll find and give
silver coins tuna volley a new hub
character allowing you to unlock new
prophecies the prophecies act as
modifiers adding guaranteed missions and
events to the generated areas of the
game such as a deadly Foss duo or a
deadly swarm of rats new rewards will be
given upon completion since you picked
the prophecy you'll know exactly what
you're getting yourself into giving you
the opportunity to prep your equipment
and abilities and don't think that will
make it easy these quests will be much
more difficult you can even change
together to create a series of
challenging quests with other own themes
and motifs this update also adds trading
between players not only allowing the
trading of items but the prophecies
themselves you can only have several
prophecies available at once so now you
can give your unwanted quests to other
players allotting slots for the
prophecies you actually want to take on
there's also one more labyrinth
challenge area being added for
high-level players it will feature
shifting environments hazardous traps
and plenty of enemies making it the most
difficult of the challenge dungeons yet
finally grinding gear is opening up to
more slots for ascendancy abilities that
means players can unlock eight of the
twelve abilities in any of the upgrade
trees granting you even more powerful
abilities for your character in addition
all that stuff you get a few minor
improvements like reduced loading times
and interface tweaks the things you
should expect from grinding gear you can
try this update out for yourself on june
third and for all your path of Exile
news stay tuned to gamespot
you
you